behind that slaughterhouse curtains I
saw two guards a walk through metal
detector and a huge gray plastic chair
the smirking guards referred to as the
Masters chair they turned me to face the
walls sticky with human sweat and blood
and told me to put my palms on it they
frisked me and pointed to the creepy
gray chair sit down lean back and don't
move said the guard he flicked the
switch jutting out from one side of the
chair which made a high piercing sound i
jolted in surprise as I correctly
guessed this sinister device is used to
check whether there is any metal inside
a detained persons body I would sit on
many chairs like that when transported
under convoy and in court buildings
everything's ok she's ours the guard
cheerfully nodded at the FBI agents
lingering in the doorway and trying to
cover their noses from the stench they
took me to the next room where on a long
wooden bench I saw a person or something
it was impossible to tell the gender
from looking at them opposite this
person was a computer desk for the guard
who signed in newcomers i sat down on
the very edge of the bench trying not to
faint from the the vile stink permeating
the room I didn't have to wait long they
took my fingerprints again and a smiling
officer looked quizzically at me and my
thin beige capri pants black top and a
throw over cardigan barely covering my
shoulders the cherry on top of this
completely out of the place look was my
unruly mane of red hair that almost
reached my waist the next step was
talking to a police psychiatrist in his
dirty poorly lit office with heaps and
heaps of papers and the bluish light
coming from an old computer screen do
you want to kill yourself no do you want
to hurt yourself no do you want to kill
anyone around you no do you want to hurt
them no having crossed the US border
multiple times I have learned not to
make jokes when talking to law
enforcement or security agencies your
joke will absolutely be held against you
are you a danger to society the officer
pressed
No have you ever tried to commit suicide
no there was no end to it at some point
to tell you the truth I really thought
that maybe if I said I was suicidal
they would send me to hospital instead
of that awful stinking pit nater it
turned out I was right not to go down
that road because self-destructive
prisoners were kept in the same
conditions as the rest with only one
exception that cherry on the cake as
American say they were put in a
straitjacket and laid out as a mummy on
a metal bunk until further notice there
was no end to it at some point to tell
you the truth I've really thought that
maybe if I said I was suicidal they
would send me to hospital instead of
that awful stinking pit later it turned
out I was right
not to go down that road because
self-destructive prisoners were kept in
the same conditions as the rest with
only one exception that cherry on the
cake as Americans say they were put in a
straitjacket and laid out as a mummy on
a metal bunk until further notice when
the police psychologist finally
exhausted all their questions
I was offered a sandwich and some juice
I wasn't hungry but my insides were
telling me to eat I made the right
choice I had to make that meager
sandwich last all the way until midnight
until then they didn't give me many food
or water all the pieces fell into place
as it became clear why my lawyer almost
begged them to let me have at least one
little bottle of water a guard pushed me
into a corridor with a small metal
staircase and we started descending from
there I could hear the dreadful sounds
of people pounding on metal shouting in
anguish all sorts of inhuman moaning and
howling shut up all of you barked the
officer into the semi-darkness
of that metal hell we walk down the
corridor surrounded by cells beyond
count men and women were clinging to the
metal netting of the doors they were
begging for water toilet paper or at
least for someone to tell them what time
it was male prisoners were raising hell
after they noticed me which put an
amused grin on the face of my guard he
me into a cell next to one with a man
the wall between us had no windows so I
couldn't see my neighbor but he
certainly liked to tune in to any sound
I made
he got so stimulated hearing me moving
around the next door and choking on my
tears that he pleasured himself loudly
all night long and I had to listen to
produce as little sound as possible I
crawled to the farthest corner of my
metal bunk and shut my mouth and my nose
tight with my hands in order not to cry
there was a black woman in the cell
across from mine I could see her through
the mesh holes and the window she had a
mop of tangled hair covered in filth and
vomit most of the time she lay on her
berth moaning and swearing at the guards
she asked for much-needed feminine
hygiene supplies but they didn't give
her any so she smeared the walls with
her blood there were no mattresses
blankets or pillows in prison each cell
was no bigger than half a train
compartment metal bunk bars had holes
drilled into them to drain ones vomit on
two prisoners underneath them or just
onto the floor there was also a metal
toilet and even a sink but there was no
water or toilet paper there were however
huge thumb sized red cockroaches it was
incredibly hot in the cells and the heat
seemed to make the prison stench a
billion times worse the guards didn't
enjoy it either as they had to descend
to this hell every 30 minutes to do
their rounds so they brought in a huge
fan and directed a powerful air current
right at ourselves it blew right through
me I shivered as I curled up in the
corner of my metal berth pressing my
knees to my chin many of the prisoners
begged to turn off that wind we were all
thrown into that basement in the midst
of summer those wearing shorts and
t-shirts with worst off I was a bit
better off relatively I quickly realized
that the warmest part of my outfit was
my thick red hair I covered myself with
it spreading it over my body towards my
feet the best I could and it helped me
warm up a bit and concentrate I'm
thinking
I was completely exhausted emotionally
after everything I'd been through I felt
an overwhelming desire to switch off and
take a nap in the twilight of my
basement not now I said to myself as my
mom used to say an evening nap
guarantees you a sleepless night and
that would be a real disaster the night
will go by faster with sleep then I
remembered about the sandwich I'd got on
my way to the cell a couple of pieces of
white bread which was moist from the
high humidity with two see-through
odorless slices of cheese and a tiny
piece of salami packed in several layers
of cling wrap I should eat a bit now
otherwise my brain will stop thinking
and that would be a disaster in these
conditions I have to concentrate as much
as I can to comprehend what's going on
and figure out what to do I reasoned
with myself it wasn't clear when I was
going to eat next so I just ate half of
it and saved the remainder for the
moment I felt hungry again I slugged
down the saccharine drink which tasted
more like Swedish water with a generous
dose of acid red dyed and juice the shot
of glucose did its job the brain kicked
in I began taking stock of the
surroundings I thought to myself what
time is it I need to know to make sure I
know when it is day and when it is night
there were no windows on the walls
certainly the light was on during the
day and at night the task of figuring
out what time provided a temporary
distraction the last thing I remembered
was that I was brought in at around 3:30
p.m. the guards did their rounds every
30 minutes that meant I could count the
rounds and calculate the right time if
they registered me by 5:00 p.m. and
there were a couple of rounds after that
it meant it was around 6:00 p.m. but
what next I had no pan wallpaper or
anything sharp to scratch the wall
toilet paper Eureka I tear it every time
the guards come down for their rounds I
immediately recalled that the other
detainees would ask for toilet paper by
extending their hands through the food
window slightly longer than the rest
with palms cupped during the next round
I did the same by squatting down close
to a small window it worked they round
some of the
coveted toilet paper around my hands I
thought well I'm being really inventive
and started counting the rounds by
tearing the paper slightly I felt the
next round had come sooner than half an
hour something must have happened I said
to myself the guard brought a teenage
Mexican over to me opened the door and
shoved her inside here's a neighbor phew
have fun girls he mumbled and shut the
door with a squeak my first fellow
inmate was no older than 16 a small
scraggy dark-skinned girl with
pitch-black short hair and big tiful
eyes she huddled herself into a corner
on the lower bench drew her sharp elbows
up to her chin and broke into tears
you